in the previous videos I described in
some detail how an HIV viral particle
gets inside of a human cell and becomes
part of its DNA and from that process we
took these four lessons about how we
might introduce innovations into
existing human systems but in global
health and health innovation in general
we're interested not only in introducing
something new to one system but also
hopefully spreading that new idea again
examples are breastfeeding exclusive
breastfeeding so that may be something
that you can introduce among one group
of women or maybe it becomes more part
of a practice in one hospital but we
would like to see these innovations
spread to other similar systems so as we
know HIV is very successful at spreading
so the last step is really what can we
learn from the way that HIV spreads from
cell to cell throughout the body so I
will try to draw yes it always looks
like a gingerbread man a human body here
here it is and take what we just went
through in terms of HIV infection of a
single cell and learn how it spreads to
other cells other similar systems
throughout the body so first we need to
focus a little bit on an existing
network inside of the human body this is
meant to represent the lymphatic system
which is a system of vessels through
which immune cells travel all throughout
the body to conduct surveillance and
fight off infection and we know that
this lymphatic system has lymph nodes
throughout and these are the things you
feel in your neck whenever you have
certain kinds of infections they spread
I'm sorry they swell which is because
you have immune cells that are very
active there that are fighting off that
infection so HIV human immunodeficiency
virus infects human immune cells the
process that I described to you in
loves virus infection of a single it
means tell and as we know HIV infection
has different modes of transmission it
can be sexual transmission mother to
child or through needles or other sub
lud board transmission so HIV goes
through the steps I described before in
an individual cell and then the immune
system recognizes this foreign invader
and starts to become activated starts to
bring in additional immune cells to the
site of infection HIV exploits that
process uses the fact that the system is
activated and that more cells are coming
to hijack and infect additional cells
going through these same steps in those
cells and spread throughout the body so
our learning here is that HIV spreads
effectively using existing networks it
uses this existing lymphatic system to
spread and in point of fact in our
studies of health innovations that have
spread successfully we find that this is
a very common feature that a new
innovation that's introduced into a
system and become part of that system
spreads to other similar systems on
existing networks so in the example that
I cited about a better quicker treatment
process for patients with a certain kind
of heart attack that process those steps
that reduced treatment times to 90
minutes or less were conveyed in various
conferences from person to person and
existing networks and more hospitals
took up that innovation and made it part
of what they do to reduce treatment
times and I'm sorry time to treatment
and improve outcomes for patients with a
certain type of heart attack so that's
our last lesson that we can take from
this biological model of efficient
spread so let me just go through and
summarize what we think we can learn
from really taking the term going viral
fairly seriously we know that HIV binds
to a pre-existing receptor on a cell so
that is
the cell is the existing system the HIV
virus particle is the new innovation
it's brought in by a pre-existing
boundary spanner then the virus makes
its message accessible it changes its
RNA into DNA DNA is the language that
cell speaks if you will the virus note
has evolved to a take up that process I
don't want to say knows that because the
virus doesn't think but it makes its
message something that the cell can can
use and it also is incredibly adaptable
this flexibility mutability of HIV is
part of what's made it so hard to block
but as a model of efficient spread
that's a learning for us as we think
about introducing a new health
innovation into a system it overcomes
resistance cells have evolved to
maintain the status quo the virus has
evolved to overcome mechanisms of
maintaining the status quo so it can
continue in the process of bringing in
total change and something totally new
to this existing system then it
integrates into the DNA that means it
becomes part of what the cell does and
it's no longer knew this is just part of
this system forever and then as I
described in this video it spreads on
existing networks to other similar
systems going through the same process
over and over so when we have something
new a new vaccine a maybe a more for
example depo provera is another one
we've studied it's a long-acting birth
control breastfeeding exclusive
breastfeeding reduced time to treatment
for patients with a certain kind of
heart attack lots of different kinds of
health innovations that we want to bring
in something totally new into an
existing health system we think that we
can learn from a virus that has evolved
to be very very good at spreading to
help us introduce change that could
actually save people's lives thank you